and that's and that's the thing at that  boot camp I could see very extreme ends  because you had the guys that were  teaching the boot camp that get laid all  the time and the guys that were going  that that didn't that didn't even know  how to talk to me like I couldn't even  have a non like they could barely have a  conversation with me were they nervous  yeah yeah they're awkward I mean some  like oh my gosh I have stories from like  this this one guy was telling me how he  was going to conquer the world  like he wanted to be like uh you know  that's that's a different type but there  is some  um  yeah and it was but the the instructors  I saw them take  probably five girls home in three days